this video is sponsored by Squarespace
stick around until the end of the video
to learn more about a deal they're
making available through my channel
Kratos is the God of War he's super
strong he has super endurance but he
remains incredibly agile when it comes
to training programs like this though a
lot of people are interested in
performing like the character I'm
discussing but a lot of other people
want to look like him so in this video I
thought why not have both in this case
function is going to follow form we're
going to train in a way that allows us
to not only look like Kratos but also
perform like it because as you'll find
out the two actually go hand in hand
foreign
lifts heavy weight in order to build his
physique obviously if he's got super
strength then he doesn't need to have a
massive physique because it's kind of
like godly power Jack's blade actually
did a cool video on this what we're
going to be using is we're going to be
borrowing some ideas from Power building
power building is a form of training
that as the name might suggest combines
powerlifting with bodybuilding the way
you do this is you lift extremely heavy
weights using the main power lifting
moves the big three at the start of your
workout and then as you move on you
shift towards more isolation work higher
rep ranges slightly lighter weights that
way you're getting the strength building
and the hypertrophy within a single
workout we're getting the strength of
Kratos I'm also getting the look of
Kratos
foreign
but the thing is the bodybuilding isn't
just about Aesthetics the bodybuilding
also provides the extra functional
performance the reason for this is that
bodybuilding uses those higher rep
ranges which are actually perfect for
training strength endurance because as
we know if you want functional strength
it's not about how much you can lift
once it's about being able to reproduce
that strength over and over if you're a
wrestler you need to be strong for the
entire bout if you're moving things as
part of your job you need to be able to
be strong for the whole working day so
it's not good enough just to be strong
once and this is where bodybuilding
comes in and why combining those things
into a single training program actually
provides better all-round performance
makes you more like Kratos at the same
time bodybuilding and higher reps are
fantastic for blood supply for creating
more blood vessels to the muscles to
actually create new blood vessels which
Supply the muscles aiding with recovery
and increasing that strength endurance
at the same time you're strengthening
the tendons and the bones this is one of
the reasons that when people switch from
bodybuilding to powerless distinct
historically they actually have
particularly good success in this area
bodybuilding isn't just about Aesthetics
it builds functional performance and
when you combine it with powerlifting
and strength training the results can be
fantastic of course this being the
bioneer channel we're going to do things
slightly differently because Kratos
needs functional strength he's fighting
massive creatures his swing his
Leviathan acts around we need to build
functional strength so what we're going
to do is swap out some of those
bodybuilding moves some of those
powerlifting moves for more functional
Alternatives by the term functional I'm
not saying how lifting is it functional
I'm just saying we're going to use some
more traditional functional tools for
example the heavy Hammer weights that
I'm using here logs and branches and
things that we find in the woods this
way we're building
multi-planar strength grip strength
learning to grip onto things that are
awkward in shape so we're combining this
with high rep ranges to build that
strength endurance as well as heavier
weights to build power at every angle
foreign
kettlebell obviously wrong God they
didn't have an ax is a bit of a gimmick
but at the same time something like this
puts the weight so offset from the
handle creating a lever arm creating
momentum as you swing it and move it and
it's so much different from picking up
something that wants to cooperate you
have to grip hard onto the handle here
which makes it great for training grip
it's perfect for Farmers walks for
swings in the transverse plane do so
much with it and that makes it perfect
for building strength endurance in a
very functional manner so we're going to
swap out some of those bodybuilding
moves for stuff like that and then at
the same time instead of lifting heavy
weights in the gym you can push a car
you can lift a heavy log you can even
press a friend overhead
foreign
[Music]
like that something like a sandbag the
weight is unaccommodating it's moving
it's wriggling it's the wrong shape it's
not even that's what lifting heavy
things is like in the real world and of
course if you're wrestling some kind of
monster or throwing logs around then
you're gonna need that same kind of
functional strength
thank you
so obviously if you're using these more
functional and dynamic movements you're
not going to be building the same kind
of Mac strength and you're certainly not
going to get as big numbers on your
deadlift your bench but that's not what
we're talking about here talking about
being able to take your strength into
the real world where one rep Maxes don't
matter that much all we're going to be
doing is focusing more on big heavy
lifts that are awkward in nature at the
start of the workout moving to longer
rep things strength endurance type
training towards the end so that we're
building that strength and that
endurance you will find a full program
flashing up on screen now and you can
also download it from the link in the
description down below you can also
check out the protein performance system
2.0 which has over two hours of
instructional video an 80 plus page
ebook that looks at all kinds of
functional training combining things
like bodybuilding powerlifting even
calisthenics brain training into one
single program that has sets and Reps
and it's far more in depth whether
you're a beginner or a pro the point
here is we've been able to take
different training disciplines and
combine them to achieve an end result in
this case training like Kratos that's
what I'm all about mixing and matching
different modalities different concepts
from different types of training and
thereby creating something new and
impressive we even had Grant
demonstrates us some tricking and
showing how his agility can also factor
in if you want to check out more of his
stuff then he's on the channel a fair
bit you can also find the link to his
YouTube channel in the description down
below either way guys thank you so much
for watching this one and I'll see you
next time
bye for now
[Music]
it's the start of a new year so what
better time to start a new project like
creating your own website the great news
is that anyone can create a website
extremely easily thanks to today's
sponsor Squarespace so Squarespace is a
website building tool that makes the
whole process as easy as possible using
Squarespace you can create beautiful
adaptive modern websites very quickly by
choosing from a host of different
templates these are all highly
customizable however meaning you can
create something completely unique to
you and your taste you'll be able to
create your own community and generate
content through members-only gated
content you've got a fully integrated
commenting system and the ability to
manage members on the Fly get e-commerce
tools for generating further revenue and
of course excellent publishing tools for
writing formatting and scheduling blog
posts and using a host of third-party
extensions and plugins you'll be able to
extend the capabilities of Squarespace
even further whether you want to manage
your inventory track shipping handle tax
reconciliation there's just so many
options here you can even hook your
website up to your social media and have
your posts from those accounts go
directly to your website some of the
biggest brands in the world use
Squarespace so there's really no limit
to what you can achieve if you want to
learn more then head over to
squarespace.com and when you're ready to
launch then head to squarespace.com
forward slash bioneer to get 10 off of
your first domain or website link will
be in the description down below huge
thank you once again to Squarespace for
sponsoring this video
and bye for now